just fire every move
touch me let me know you wanted to
[Music]
we
we need
it's a moment that I've been waiting for
this is the original first generation
iPhone this is the 8 gigabyte model I
got it on eBay and I don't even know if
it's legit but I'm pretty sure it is
I searched the serial number the IMEI
number and everything seems to have
checked out it hasn't been activated the
serial number has never been registered
with Apple fingers crossed because I am
doing today an unboxing of the first
generation iPhone and it's crazy because
I never did do an unboxing over the
first gen iPhone the only unboxing that
I did do of the original iPhone was a
phone bill you guys have never seen this
this is back in the day when I'd first
got my phone it was a 300-page iPhone
bill so essentially in some sort of
weird roundabout way I did unbox this
phone just phone bill have an idea and I
had to switch to AT&T okay that's
wonderful while I got my first 18d built
[Music]
in a box
this phone means so much to me and
there's a lot of sentimental value and
the fact that I never really got a
chance to unbox the original one may
have been scouring eBay for the past
couple of years trying to find one that
was legit within minutes we will know I
feel like this is such a big moment I
don't even know what to do like I should
I I don't know should I put on a party
dress or something I'm not I don't know
I maybe I just open it hope for the best
what knife would I have used in 2007 I
don't even know some of the concerns
that I have on this box that may
potentially lead me to believe that it's
not real is this little packaging line
right here there's a few tears of
greater this has been around for 11
years so it's trying to find some
original unboxings and I saw some
original photos and in those original
photos of the original iPhone it looked
like they used to have this type of line
in packaging so I thought it's gotta be
real I think I'm putting too much hope
and effort into boxing this one I just
could open it and find out here we go
we're gonna use this one wow this is a
lot of pressure oh gosh I'm so signed so
I might cry this is so stupid don't cry
just seemed oh cried don't be a baby oh
my gosh this is happening it's happening
it's happening oh wow
here it is
what's my heart rate
I caught my heart rate is that it's
actually 92 right now which is kind of
crazy because that's not what my resting
heart rate usually is it's averaging of
like oh my god it's 111 right now my
heart rate is 111 112 I'm getting so
worked up please don't cry
[Applause]
[Music]
like I'm actually getting a really
teary-eyed right now and like whether
this is real or whether it's not the
fact that I'm here unboxing this 11
years later and I'm still doing
something that I absolutely love to do
is so incredible I'm so emotional right
now this is actually crazy I oh so far
this looks pretty legit
[Music]
there's like a little dad here oh gosh
no my baby my baby so far everything
looks pretty good before we get into the
phone let's see what else is in the box
so has this clear little front I don't
even remember doing this unboxing
originally here it is everything is very
snugly fit in here which makes me
believe this has never been opened
before a charging brick a dock I do not
even remember this coming with a dog
that's crazy
here's our charging cable oh my gosh
you are such a sweet so it's all I have
not seen you in so long and last but not
least earpods definitely having some
flashbacks to this 30 pin connector I
mean I haven't seen one of these in such
a long time I guess I saw on the 3GS but
still I honestly forgot that they even
had this now let's see what came inside
of these directions
you don't want to rip it this is this is
my baby
fingertips oh hello came with a nice
cleaning cloth lay you down very very
gently that's what we're gonna put you
here's our directions I mean there's
there's a lot
[Music]
we've also got the original white
stickers I am putting this all back
right where I got it from important
product information this just looks like
some safety things I think contain
sensitive components do not bend drop a
crush I felt your concern about
scratching iPhone you can buy one of the
many cases sold separately I should do a
dramatic reading of this for a YouTube
video I might as well I'm gonna be
milking these iPhone original views for
a very long time enjoy an unboxing and
also re boxing because I don't want any
of my things to get damaged so I guess
this only leaves us with one more thing
to do unwrap the phone and turn it on
let's get our charging brick ready that
is that is really on there you like it's
gonna rip this whole screen off I guess
this has been on there for doesn't have
a smell for like a what 11 years do you
guys think this will actually turn on do
you think this will even work at all
it's charging it's charging there's a
charging if there's there's a charge
look look look it's charging I am so
excited I'm gonna let this charge for a
little bit and then I'm gonna come back
and we will just do some investigating
just see what we can do with this thing
just been walking around the house
patiently waiting for this moment let's
see if it'll turn on Oh what you may
have connected to iTunes that's a
problem oh no I can't do that this
version of iTunes has not been out for
11 years okay well if it wants me to
connect it iTunes then that's what I'm
gonna do
I know I know you know I know I'm Shh
calm yourself opening up iTunes itunes
cannot connect to the iPhone because an
invalid response is received from the
device it's valid let me let show me oh
god how am I gonna even get this thing
to work
oh boy okay download full version of
iTunes I can't use this okay so I'm good
to go getting it a PC this is gonna work
I promise
actually I don't promise supported
systems Windows XP well on my own this
is not gonna work oh gosh the real
bottom line is the phone is legit it
looks brand-new it's never been
activated before I don't have to
jailbreak it Oh will I have to jailbreak
it I'm not sure this is gonna take a lot
more time than I have currently right
now to dedicate to this but stay tuned
because I will get this phone to work no
matter what I have to do well guys thank
you so much for watching I look forward
to doing a little bit more of
investigating with this phone I'll see
you guys in the next video I'm gonna get
back to working if you guys have any
suggestions for me leave those in the
comments below as of this point I have
done absolutely zero research on how to
get this to work so I have a feeling
that between your comments my google
searches and a little bit more
investigation we will be able to get
this thing up and running in no time
this is no that's not what I wanted to
do yeah do whatever you want
[Music]
[Applause]